you know as we arrived here today biagio
you kind of told this you know we
mentioned we want to talk pitching and
you said that you had done something in
Cleveland where you kind of put together
almost like a pitch seminar was it with
it in Cleveland I get that right it
wasn't that wasn't clear it wasn't
cleaning and you actually had success
where to soap to shows were sold can you
just give us a little bit more I know
what you guys are doing absolutely well
one of the things you know if you visit
our blog which is joke and Biagio calm
if you spell out if you google it even
close you'll find it I'm the very fun
page it says come sell a TV show with us
and one of the things that we wanted to
do for people that are where we were ten
years ago is make it easier to pitch
your unscripted television ideas you
know we're documentarians were
unscripted television producers we do a
documentary series reality TV we're
always looking for ideas and so one of
the things that we've been trying to do
is make it easier for people who have
ideas to pitch to us so what what we
have the way that we pick shows is with
video pitches that is how we sell TV
shows so it speaks a lot to what we were
just talking about now a video pictures
to sell a television show is a little
bit different than the video pitch to to
get someone on board your kickstarter
campaign but a lot of the techniques are
the same and that you know you the
passion for your show needs to come
through but it's not you on tape
pitching your show it's you actually
going out and capturing footage of
interesting characters and and what I
talk about unscripted television I'm not
talking about like survivor or big
brother we're going to be a lot less
useful if your pitches it's survivor in
the Arctic or it's you know it's
survivor but with acrobats or its
American Idol for bartenders it's no no
everybody pitches those shows nobody
wants them um what the types of shows
that we're looking for our shows that
feature real people in interesting
worlds I mean if you had found the guys
from Pawn Stars in your hometown that
would be amazing you know who are the
swamp people where you live you know
what's the really interesting business
or the really interesting family or
story or entity in your town that nobody
knows about because all the producers
are in LA in New York in your in Middle
America somewhere so what we did
recently was we went to Cleveland and we
did a two-part seminar is next
and in part one we sat down for two days
and we're like look this is what a good
TV show is this is what a good TV
pitches is what a bad don't
pitch a survivor in the Arctic don't
pitch us a game show don't pitch us
anything that you're gonna you know that
is like a Biggest Loser ripoff you know
do pitch us you know shows about real
people do look at shows like Pawn Stars
an ax men and um you know swamp people
and the shows that people are buying
right now and then try and find what is
that show in your hometown because right
now the best place to be to sell a TV
show is any place except New York or Los
Angeles every network wants to do shows
someplace else so guess what if you're
not New York in LA for the first time
you have a leg up on everybody on the
coasts when you do do that pitch tape
what are we looking for think about it
as like a mini movie trailer for your
reality TV idea I mean that's really
what it is it's you know it's three to
six minutes that really gives an idea of
what your show is who the characters are
and what types of conflicts they go
through every week and whereas earlier
we're talking about you know what's your
what's your call to action what's your
cell you know in a pitch video and a TV
pitch tape your call to action is hey
come watch this kind of show every week
so as it is it every week I'm going to
see these guys you know round up a bunch
of alligators and you know or we're
going to see them you know every week
these guys try to earn enough money to
keep their bar open and you're asking
people to commit to a certain kind of
show and understanding what it is you're
seeing every week is it every week see
you know this group of adventurers
search for gold you know what is it that
these real people are doing every single
week and that's your call to action in
that kind of video so we did this
two-part class in Cleveland as an
experiment and two we teamed up with two
young producers whose ideas that we
liked and soul both of them one which is
going to be an arable pilot I can't say
which network yeah but we'll be able to
say soon and one which is going to be a
pilot for another network which is great
so these people who had no producer
credits we teamed up with them they're
going to be producers on the show and
they're going to work on the show in
different ways the reason we love
working with filmmakers is because in
unscripted television you don't get paid
a bunch of money to walk away if you
come and you bring us an idea and you
don't want to work on the show you can
hope to maybe make anywhere between a
thousand
three thousand dollars in episode to do
nothing which is not bad money to do
nothing but if you can actually work on
the show if you're a good shooter or
you're a good editor you know or you're
a great story producer you're
interviewing people whatever your skills
are you can actually get paid to do that
on the show and make even more money so
that's why we look to team up with
filmmakers and that's how we started out
we started out as filmmakers with show
ideas we teamed up with bigger
production companies and eventually got
to a point where we could be the
production company so if you go to our
site you can read about how to pitch to
us it's really easy we just ask that you
don't pitch a survivor in the Arctic or
anything that feels like a big silly
reality game show that's not what we're
looking for willing for great
documentary series and reality shows
about real people that we haven't seen
before what he said
you